rescuers have deployed floats to mark
the location of the wreck as it settles
on the seabed and they're pumping air
into the hull to help anyone who might
still be alive so far there's been one
small success divers were able to reach
the ship's cargo hold but they found no
sign of anyone there it's an agonizing
wait for the relatives more information
is emerging about the ferries last
moments the vessel made an abrupt turn
and that could have caused cargo to
shift and destabilize the ship
investigators are asking if Freight
should have been better secured at the
time of the accident the captain seen
here being questioned by the Coast Guard
wasn't on the bridge only the third
officer while this is not unusual the
less experienced officer may not have
been ready to handle an emergency even
worse the captain told the passengers to
remain in their places the ferry became
a death trap while the captain and most
of the crew abandoned ship the accident
has now claimed another victim the
assistant director of the high school
where most of the missing students came
from hanged himself near the site of the
sinking he was one of the few who
managed to get off the ship alive